je paie pas pour mes filles en 2015 ces
femmes autochtones se confie à
l'émission enquête
quatre ans plus tard après avoir lu et
entendu plus de 1000 témoignage l'ex
juge jacques bien dresse un constat
brutal au terme de l'exercice écrit-il
il me semble impossible de nier la
discrimination systémique dont sont
victimes les membres des premières
nations et les inuit dans leurs
relations avec les services publics
ayant fait l'objet de l'enquêté
de nombreuses lois politiques normes
pratiques institutionnelles en place
sont des sources de discrimination udine
quitté le commissaire rappelle
l'histoire du colonialisme évoque une
responsabilité partagée
il parle de la faillite du système
public et montre du doigt entre autres
les ministères de la sécurité publique
de la santé et des services sociaux de
même que les services de protection de
la jeunesse
plus encore que leurs droits selon
l'unité de milliers de gens qui est
ainsi spolie dans une société développée
comme l'anneau
ce constat est simplement inacceptable
mais le rapport laisse sur leur faim
plusieurs groupes
la présidente de femmes autochtones du
québec déplore le peu d'attention
accordée aux victimes d'abus sexuels à
l'origine de l'anc et moi ça me dépasse
aujourd'hui bravo pour mener les travaux
qui ont été faits mais le plus gros
manquements ça a été la sécurité
le commissaire recommande au
gouvernement de présenter des excuses
publiques à tous les autochtones mais
cela ne convainc pas non plus si tu
entends des excuses sans qu'il y ait des
coûts des actions contre les actions
viendront assure le gouvernement qui a
déjà organisé un grand rendez vous avec
les chefs des communautés le 17 octobre
et c'est vraiment un travail
d'évaluation et de priorisation qu'on
veut faire d'ici là le premier ministre
s'adressera aux autochtones à
l'assemblée nationale mercredi
dior effectivement beaucoup de choses
inquiétantes dans le rapport et puis il
faut changer les façons dont on donne
des services aux autochtones au québec
j'en deviens met en garde le
gouvernement des rapports précédents sur
des enjeux apparentés n'ont jamais eu de
suivi ce qui a contribué à exacerber le
cynisme des membres des premières
nations pour éviter que son propre
rapport ne subisse le même sort
il recommande au gouvernement d'en
confier le suivi à la protectrice du
citoyen ici ou là vallée radio canada
québec